Senator Tim Scott has gone on to the
view he's gone into the lion's den the
Cougars Den the I don't know I don't
know what animals they are he's gone
into some sort of den
and he's defended his position as a
republican specifically as a black
Republican and he did it pretty
successfully
you have indicated that you don't
believe in systemic racism what is your
definition of systemic racism let me ask
answer the question that you've answered
or does it even exist in your mind let
me answer the question this way one of
the things I think about and one of the
reasons why I'm on the show is because
of the comments that were made frankly
on this show that the only way for a
young African-American kid to be
successful in this country is to be the
exception and not the role that is a
dangerous offensive disgusting message
to send to our young people today that
the only way to succeed is by being the
exception I will tell you that if my
life is the exception I can't imagine I
can't it is but it's not actually here's
here's 114 years yeah so so the fact of
the matter is we've had an
African-American president
African-American vice president we've
had two African-Americans to be
secretaries of the state the fact of the
matter is that progress in America is
palpable it could be measured in
Generations I look back at the fact that
my grandfather born in 1921 in Sally
South Carolina when he was on a on a
sidewalk a white person was coming he
had to step off and not make eye contact
that man believed then with some doubt
now in the goodness of America
Tim Scott is really great in this
setting
Tim Scott is not great on campaign rally
stages you might remember his campaign
announcement was not quite at a Howard
Dean level of yeah but but it was
bordering on that and then the
microphone went out and he handled it as
well as he could but that's not where he
shines there are many candidates who do
a lot better on the campaign rally stage
Tim Scott does really really well here
I've only gotten to meet Senator Scott I
think a couple of times now he was on
the verdicts podcast with Ted Cruz when
I hosted that show and
one-on-one in an intimate setting he's
great he's really really persuasive
compelling seems like a really sincere
genuine guy and so when everything's a
little quieter and toned down here and
he can just make his case to the women
on The View
that's really compelling stuff
the problem for Tim Scott's presidential
campaign
is where the conversation went next
so what I'm suggesting is that the
yesterday's exception is today's Rule
and for us Jessica has met its promise
no of course the the concept of America
is that we are going to become a more
perfect union but in fact the challenges
that we face
50 years ago and 60 years ago should not
be the same challenges that we face
today and here's a way that you you
measured that when my mother was born
about 10 of African Americans got a high
school degree diploma today is over 90
when you look at the income when you
look at the income when you look at this
when you look at that everything's
getting better so so Tim Scott is
making his presidential campaign
a progressive presidential campaign
head on over to carson.com Knowles
buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for anyone especially if
you're a first-time buyer or have no
credit before you walk into a dealership
and spend the entire day with the crowds
stress and potential to not even find
the right car you need to check out
carzing carsing is completely changing
the way you buy a car online by
partnering with Credit Agencies lenders
and over 25 000 dealers Nationwide
carsing provides you with everything you
need before stepping foot into a
dealership once you find the right car
at your ideal budget all you have to do
is bring your saved deal voucher with
you to the dealership to finalize your
next ride it is super simple even if
you're not in the market for a new car
check out cars saying anyway carsing's
online window shopping experience goes
beyond mirror images you can dive deep
into each vehicle's specifications
features and performance capabilities
zoom in on craftsmanship of the Interior
Marvel at Cutting Edge technology and
admire the meticulous attention to
detail that sets these automobiles apart
from the rest chorusing helps make your
experience faster cheaper less stressful
go to carson.com Knowles find the best
deals near you carson.com Knowles right
now go to ramp.com Knowles are you
looking for a better way to simplify
your business finances across expenses
vendor payments and accounting if so
ramp could be a complete game changer
for your business ramp is a corporate
card and expense management software
designed to help you save time and money
with ramp you can issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
and automate expense reporting so you
can stop wasting time at the end of
every month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to the time you'll
save each month on employee expenses
will allow you to close your books eight
times faster businesses that use Ram
save an average of 3.5 percent within
the first year ramp is easy to use get
started in less than 15 minutes whether
you have five employees or five thousand
right now get 250 dollars when you join
ramp just go to ramp.com Knowles that is
ramp.com
issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic Bank
members FDIC terms and conditions apply
his
pitch is that America is always getting
better and so things might not be right
now but they're going to be better in
the future and so stop complaining and
don't
don't you know raise questions that are
too too harsh about America because look
at how much better things are today than
they used to be
and there are a lot of Republicans who
have made this sort of an argument
and in certain cases I guess it's true
in certain cases things are better today
than they used to be but in other cases
they're not that's true for everybody
that's true he's talking there
specifically about Black Americans in
certain ways the lives of black
Americans are better today than they
used to be in many ways though they're
worse
out of wedlock births are way worse
right now than they used to be for black
Americans marriage rates way lower than
they used to be for black Americans
crime rates murder rates way worse than
so things aren't just totally getting
better
the country is not in a place right now
where either side wants to hear oh
America is doing really really great
stop complaining just
grit your teeth and bear it put a smile
on your face and if we wish that the
country is in nice shape maybe it will
be
think about Trump's campaign Trump's
successful campaign in 2016 was the
countries in absolute turmoil were all
living in the gutter the country is as
bad as it's ever been and we need to
make America great again
that's very different from the Rosy
kind of right-wing liberal Progressive
conservative I know these it sounds like
these words are contradictory but
they're not really the
not radical Progressive view but the
kind of conservative Progressive view of
Tim Scott he says things are keep
getting better and don't worry they're
they're going to continue to get better
into the future
I don't know that that's going to work
I don't think that's where the country
is right now I certainly don't think
that's where the Republican party is
right now
and it only tells half the story
and I think if you're going to make a
pitch right now where we've got
really low
approval of of where the country is I
think you've got to tell that other half
of the story which is no a lot of things
have gotten worse and a lot of things
have gotten worse because of
progressivism if Tim Scott's going to
run a progressive presidential campaign
he's going to end up in the same
position
that desantises is likely going to end
up in with Donald Trump which is why
would you vote for the imitation when
you can get the original why would you
vote for the imitation Progressive when
you can get the tried and true OG
Progressive Democrat
why would you go to Pete's Coffee when
you can get Starbucks why would you go
to Carl's Jr today when you could get
McDonald's
why would you vote for a guy who says no
progress is happening and progress is
good when you can get when you get the
person who really totally believes that
with all of its implications
he's got to work that out he could be a
really compelling presidential candidate
especially if he can play to his
strengths like in those more intimate
settings which today with with the way
social media work you probably could do
that but he's gotta I think he's got a
fine tune that message boy what a great
clip that was make sure you ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel see you next time